These are some things I prep
to make my week just a little bit easier.
Usually I use my ripe bananas to make banana bread,
but today I decided to make oatmeal bake muffins.
These are a one bowl recipe as well,
which makes clean up really easy.
So I mixed all of my ingredients
and then chopped up my chocolate
and dried cherries that I'm gonna add to it,
scooped all of that in my little muffin pan,
slid that in the oven.
While those were baking,
I started on my date caramel.
I've been obsessed with having this
with apples and different kinds of fruits.
So I soak my dates
and then blend them up with some coconut milk,
and it comes out tasting exactly like caramel does.
Citrus is the best in winter,
so I always stock up on it.
And I've been loving fresh squeezed orange juice,
not the store bought ones,
so I decided to just make a big glass that I can have
throughout the week.
Also, pulp and orange juice is a must.
Don't even fight me on that.
And I moved on to making a quick Mediterranean salad.
So I chopped up some cucumbers,
some bell peppers,
added some chickpeas,
some feta cheese,
some parsley,
and top that with a balsamic maple dressing.
Stores so well in the fridge.
I eat it with chips,
I eat it on bread,
I eat it by itself.
It's really good
and it doesn't go bad.
Or at least a week.
Then I moved on to making an Asian pickled
cucumber salad.
I love having this.
It's super simple.
I pickled it with some rice vinegar,
sugar, sesame seeds,
chilli, and then
I like prepping one warm and comforting meal.
So today it was a Thai red curry
chopped up on my vegetables
and then fried
some lemongrass and red curry paste in some oil.
Added my coconut milk,
all of my veggies,
some chicken,
let that simmer while I packed up my oatmeal
baked muffins.
Once that was done,
I transferred that over to some glass Tupperware,
let that cool down completely before closing,
and that's what I prepped for this week.